so I want to talk about a wreath rotol
it's a sugar alcohol but it doesn't have
alcohol and it sometimes have people
have a confusion thinking that they're
consuming alcohol now it has no alcohol
in it
wreath or tall is an alternative
sweetener it's seventy percent of the
sweetness as actual table sugar but it
has a cooling factor so it's kind of
like a cold sensation it's zero on the
glycemic index so it does not increase
your blood Sugar's bacteria have a hard
time consuming this sugar so you're not
going to have as much digestive problem
as other sugar alcohols like Malta tall
will that actually creates a lot of
bloating and gas this one you'd have to
consume a little bit more before you
have that effect but in large quantities
you're going to have a laxative effect
stomach rumbling and probably a lot of
gas okay now a lot of products that use
this alternative sugar also use inulin
this is misspelled in Ulan okay this is
a fiber from Chickering root and from
other things as well this is the thing
that causes more bloating because it's a
soluble fiber which is consumed by the
microbes because microbes eat fiber and
they ferment and you can get a lot of
gas and bloating so if you were to
consume this without em Yulin you'd
probably be better off and probably in
small quantities it might be okay so
what is the problem with three-foot-tall
well there's several ways they make it
if it's made with yeast its fed glucose
from corn in most corn is GMO which
means it's laced with glyphosate and
herbicide so that is the big problem and
I think there's basically I would look
at the wreath roll is two different
versions the GMO version and the non GMO
version I think a lot of the bad things
you've seen about arethe throat roll on
the Internet is pretty much only because
it's GML because you're consuming a
product that's been exposed to GMO corn
and that's the problem so what I
recommend it yes I would recommend it
just make sure it is
GMO arethe rotol alright thanks for
watching
hey I appreciate your attention and if
you're enjoying these videos go ahead
and subscribe and I will definitely keep
you updated on future events live events
and webinars that we're going to do very
soon